13 55 bonjour bienvenue doit-on
s'attendre au pire Vladimir Poutine
prend la parole d'une minute à l'autre
chacun de ces discours fait désormais
trembler le monde occidental n'a-t-il
pas réussi en cela son son pari que
peut-il annoncer hormis l'annonce c'est
ce qui est prévu de l'annexion des
territoires ukrainien Fabrice n'a de
nombreux bonjour bonjour Thibault vous
êtes rédacteur en chef du service
économie international et puis vous êtes
ancien correspondant du Figaro à Moscou
lorsqu'on voit ses images là c'est assez
impressionnant et c'est assez rare vous
me disiez oui on s'attendait pas
forcément à ce que la locution de
Vladimir Poutine se fait dans ce dans ce
cadre si solennel un des grands hall du
Kremlin devant des j'ai l'impression des
centaines de personnes en tout cas
disait le vraiment tout toute la le
gratin du pouvoir russe il y a bien sûr
des ministres
on aperçu tout à l'heure
ramsane Kadirov le président de
dont on sait qu'il a envoyé des hommes
des des soldats en
Ukraine il y a des leaders religieux
face à ressemble aux adresses annuelles
que la lumière Poutine fait devant
effectivement absolument tout ce que le
pouvoir russe compte de de gens
puissants dans l'administration les élus
les représentants des des régions des
services etc évidemment des des galonner
donc ça il a vraiment voulu solenniser
cette adresse donc lui rendre un
caractère historique ce qu'on va plus se
contenter de une allocution dans votre
bureau
ces dernières semaines comme il l'a fait
hier soir d'ailleurs également ce qu'on
va faire c'est que à 14h lorsque
Vladimir Poutine va s'exprimer on va
l'écouter en russe et nous reviendrons
de temps en temps
ensemble pour vous expliquer ce qu'il
est en train de dire est-ce que cela
implique pourquoi est-ce qu'on a un peu
peur Fabrice peur c'est un bien grand
mot peut-être mais on est inquiet et là
le monde entier regarde les discours de
Vladimir Poutine mais on est à 7 mois de
guerre en Ukraine on sait qu'il y a eu
un tournant majeur c'est ces derniers
jours ces dernières semaines alors d'une
part avec la contre-offensive
ukrainienne dans la région de kerkivent
surtout qui a suscité cet appel à la
mobilisation partielle pour reprendre le
terme de Vladimir facile mobilisation on
sait qui est très compliqué sur place
qui a fait fuir des dizaines de milliers
de Russes à l'étranger
ce qui pose du coup qui suscite des
questions des interrogations au sein du
pouvoir russe qui est extrêmement opaque
on est toujours un peu comme à l'époque
soviétique les criminologues font
surtout des supputations c'est toujours
très difficile de savoir quels sont les
luttes d'influence au sein du Kremlin si
Poutine et obéi aveuglément si des gens
essayent de de lui désobéir s'il y a des
on voit monsieur
Ivanov qui fut un temps il y a longtemps
un ministre de la Défense désigné il y a
une quinzaine d'années comme successeur
possible de Poutine comme d'autres
personnes après la crème de la crème de
la puissance russe et dans cette salle
oui oui absolument
je crois que c'est le ministre actuel
shoego
y compris par des gradés
de santé ou pas c'est vraiment des très
proches de Poutine
alors pour répondre à votre question oui
pourquoi on peut avoir peur parce que
Vladimir Poutine a été quand même
extrêmement
diplomatie depuis quasiment le début de
l'ère Poutine
et donc oui pourquoi pourquoi craindre
cette prise de parole parce que quand
même Vladimir Poutine a fait des menaces
très explicites d'un usage possible
possible aux harmonucléaires pour
défendre le territoire russe puisque si
l'annexe effectivement les régions
ukrainiennes où il y a eu ces
parodies de référendum comme a priori
c'est l'information principale qui
devrait être annoncée aujourd'hui encore
on ne sait évidemment pas exactement ce
qu'ils vont se lancer c'est ça
officiellement il prend la parole pour
dire que le territoire russe s'agrandit
voilà parce que on peut le rappeler
depuis une semaine un peu plus il y a eu
des référendum en Russie alors ça
pourrait revenir qui bon sont pas
forcément dans un cadre extrêmement
légal et certainement pas reconnu
Nations Unies personne et aujourd'hui
donc annonce la Russie s'agrandit c'est
ça l'objectif le premier objectif on est
d'accord que c'est ça oui ça grandit et
ça change tout du point de vue
défense c'est-à-dire que c'est ce que
Poutine a dit si les Ukrainiens
attaquent
ce que les ukrainiens et la communauté
internationale considère comme des
territoires ukrainiens
occupé mais que Moscou considéra
maintenant comme partie intégrante du
territoire russe Moscou sera en droit le
Kremlin de se défendre par tous les
moyens c'est ça c'est c'est vraiment la
l'axe principale et de nos
interrogations aujourd'hui 4 régions
très proche collaborat collaborateur de
Poutine qui fut son premier ministre
prési présent lors de cette intermède
très étonnant parce que Vladimir Poutine
respectait la constitution qu'il
empêchait de se présenter pour un
troisième mandat avant de revenir
Dimitri medvedef qui dans les années
2000-2008 quand il était président
à droite là qui passait à l'époque
auprès de la communauté internationale
plutôt pour un libéral modernisateur et
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être l'une des
voiles et les plus agressives qui
régulièrement fait des déclarations
extrêmement violentes à l'égard de
l'Occident qui qui surprennent quand on
l'a connu il y a 10-15 ans il est devenu
vraiment j'ai toujours proche de
Vladimir Poutine alors vous savez ça
c'est de dire vraiment qui est proche ou
pas en attendant toujours dire oui on
s'approche mais en tout cas il sait que
il a plus grand chose à perdre qu'il a
tout intérêt à coller au régime et il
est d'une agressivité incroyable dans
ces menaces dans ses critiques à l'égard
de l'Occident 14h Vladimir Poutine doit
prendre la parole d'un instant à l'autre
pour annoncer officiellement l'annexion
de quatre régions ukrainiennes Donetsk
Lougansk zapporja Kerson à partir de ce
moment là et c'est l'enjeu principal aux
yeux de la Russie ces territoires
deviennent russes donc si les Ukrainiens
venaient à les reprendre sur le terrain
les attaqueraient le territoire russe ça
permet à Vladimir Poutine aux yeux de
son opinion pour le pour les gens qui
continuent à croire aveuglément dans la
dans la propagande russe de dire mais
c'est nous maintenant qui sommes
agressés
ce qui permet de changer le récit et
c'est là que la menace de l'arme
nucléaire intervient il l'a beaucoup
agité cette menace ces derniers temps on
s'attend à ce qu'il le fasse encore
aujourd'hui alors verbalement oui oui
sans doute après on va voir mais c'est
encore une fois ce qui est assez
frappant c'est de ce cadre de décorum
solennelle qui a été
convoqué pour pour cette annonce qui
aurait pu être fait dans un des bureaux
de du président russe comme
régulièrement il l'utilise depuis 7 mois
que que cette guerre a commencé alors si
on attend
on peut
rappeler qu'il y a un précédent qu'on a
un petit peu tendance à oublier mais oui
bientôt 9 ans la Crimée a été annexée il
y a eu aussi un référendum à l'époque
qui d'ailleurs était peut-être un petit
alors qu'il n'a pas été reconnu du tout
par la communauté intern
presqu'île bien sûr à l'Ukraine et la
Russie a extrêmement rapidement
construit un pont qui permet de rallier
le l'est de la péninsule de Crimée au
reste du continent au reste de la Russie
pleinement rattachée cette péninsule la
Crimée à la Russie et alors à l'époque
bien sûr nationale avait
fait
partition mais la réaction n'avait quand
même pas été si forte on avait un peu
l'impression que la Crimée passait
passée par pertes et profits et alors
pourquoi pourquoi cette différence cette
fois alors c'était un peu la alors c'est
qu'il y a pas eu de guerre sanglante la
Crimée a été a été annexée finalement
alors par ces fameux hommes en verre
qu'on appelait des soldats russes qui
n'avaient même pas l'uniforme
officiels je n'ai pas été vérifié mais
il n'y a quasiment pas eu de de violence
lors de l'annexion de la Crimée en tout
cas certainement pas de combat ça a été
fait extrêmement rapidement
l'Ukraine a été mise devant le fait
accompli on n'était pas dans le même
contexte de vrais guerres ouvertes et la
communauté internationale on peut
certains pourront dire je pense à juste
raison qu'elle a été d'une elle a fait
montre d'une certaine lâcheté en tout
cas un peu passée la Crimée par perte et
profits tout en montant se format qu'on
a appelé Nord
ce contexte de guerre était pas tout à
fait le même si vous l'avez dit il y a
une invasion russe sur le territoire
ukrainien mais on n'est pas dans une
guerre totale comme Vladimir Poutine a
essayé de l'amener fin février il n'y
avait pas non plus volody mirzelenski à
la tête du pays qui a quand même su
galvanisé son son peuple
donc le contexte est différent mais il
faut pas oublier qu'il a déjà une région
ukrainienne la stratégiquement
importante la Crimée qui a été annexée
de facto par la Russie 14h06 nous
attendons Vladimir Poutine il doit
prendre la parole d'un instant à l'autre
le décor est superbe splendide assez
impressionnant il faut bien le dire
la Russie depuis la région de
Saint-Pétersbourg jusqu'au nord de
l'Allemagne en passant par la mer
Baltique il faut poser sur le fond de la
mer Baltique
les pouvoirs les gouvernants notamment
Angela Merkel tenaient beaucoup à ce que
c'est gazoduc soit soit construit il en
a eu un premier ordre stream
en réalité c'est déjà deux tuyaux
inaugurés en 2011 North stream 2 ensuite
qui devait doubler la capacité de
livraison de gaz russe vers l'Europe
occidentale était achevée juste au
moment où la guerre en Ukraine a été
déclenchée d'accord il était
techniquement terminé les Américains ont
fait une forte pression pour que
l'Allemagne ne donne pas le dernier feu
vert administratif pour que ce gazoduc
fonctionne donc il n'a jamais fonctionné
notre stream 2 et début septembre les
Russes avaient stoppé les livraisons du
bras de fer donc on est d'accord que
c'est deux Nord Stream c'est de gaz
ne transmettez pas de gaz à l'Europe
et là énorme coup de théâtre cette
semaine il y a des fuites énormes de gaz
donc des bouillonnements très visibles à
la surface de l'eau je pense que si vous
avez vu c'est ces images c'est respecté
donc effectivement on a parlé de trois
puis quatre fuites de gaz donc personne
ne croit un incident
alors ce qui est très mystérieux dans
cette histoire c'est qu'on se dit à qui
profite le crime pourquoi les Russes
s'aboteraient
eux-mêmes ça peut être utile eux-mêmes
ce gazoduc alors même qu'il ne
transmettent pas de gaz pour l'instant
de gaz que c'est une source de revenus
importante en même temps quand on parle
à des spécialistes on voit vraiment pas
quel autre état serait permettez-moi
pardonnez-moi l'expression serait assez
tordu pour pour faire une telle
opération alors pour la lumière Poutine
si il le sait lui Joe Biden et les
États-Unis
oui et c'est intéressant de voir que
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux tout
la mouvance proche de Trump accuse
directement Joe Biden et donc la CIA ou
les États-Unis le Deep state comme on
dit la musique officielle l'état profond
d'avoir d'être à l'origine de ce de
sabotage il se nourrissent de
déclarations qui ont été réelles en
début 2022 fin 2021 ou effectivement
l'administration démocrate disait il
faut arrêter ce gazoduc c'est un moyen
de pression terrible de la Russie sur
l'Europe ne le mettez pas en service le
nom de stream 2 donc effectivement ça
c'est une réalité il y a eu des
pressions américaines mais de là saboter
ça paraît quand même assez fou et il
faut pas oublier que quand même le
pouvoir russe et les services russes
sont capables de coûts tordu moi j'aime
bien rappeler quand même ce qui est
souvent ce que moi j'appelle
du régime Poutine on est en 1999
Vladimir Poutine est tout juste nommé
Premier ministre de Boris eltine il
dirigeait le FSB donc descendant du KGB
il y a une série d'explosion à Moscou et
dans des villes de province qui font
plusieurs dizaines de morts parmi des
civils russes on accuse des terroristes
tchétchen ont déclenche une guerre en
Tchétchénie c'est la deuxième guerre de
Tchétchénie on a très vite su que le FB
était derrière ses attentats donc faut
pas oublier quand même que le pouvoir
russe ne recule devant
aucun genre de manoeuvre même quand ça
coûte des vies humaines là en
l'occurrence North stream n'a pas coûté
de vie humaine mais encore une fois on
n'a pas d'explication il faut être très
prudent je vous avais raison
en tout cas peu de doute que Vladimir
Poutine ça exprimera aussi sur sur cette
question dans ce discours autre oui vous
pensez qu'il non il passera ça sous le
chapeau on en parle pas c'est une belle
on va découvrir ça on va découvrir ça
évidemment autre possibilité
dans ce discours c'est qu'il fasse qu'il
parle de cette mobilisation partielle de
tous ces russes qui quittent le pays
depuis quelques semaines depuis quelques
jours depuis son annonce la semaine
dernière de cette mobilisation partielle
qui lui permet de récupérer plus
d'hommes c'est ça c'est très compliqué
on a vu que cette
jusqu'à depuis février jusqu'à cette
mobilisation une partie de la population
russe pouvait mettre totalement de côté
cette guerre en Ukraine qui ne
n'affectait pas directement sa vie
on sait qu'il y a certainement beaucoup
plus de morts de soldat russe qui sont
morts que les chiffres officiels ne
pas plus oui
les sources occidentales parlent de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers bon ça on
n'en sait rien c'est sûr qu'il y a quand
même des milliers de familles russes qui
ont été touchés mais il n'y avait on n'a
pas vu de manifestations de maire de
soldats russes par exemple là avec cette
mobilisation il y a une toute autre
ampleur et c'est quand on voit ces
dizaines de milliers de d'hommes et
souvent avec leur famille quand ils
peuvent avec leurs compagnes qui fut le
pays là la guerre a vraiment pris un
autre tournant et Vladimir Poutine là
bien vu l'effet que ça faisait à tel
point qu'il a en partie rétro pédalé
c'est quand même rare de la part de
pouvoir expliquer un peu des des mauvais
interprétations des erreurs on va revoir
au cas par cas c'est pas normal que des
gens malades soient mobilisés que des
gens d'un certain âge soient mobilisés
lui-même un peu voilà rétropédaler et
c'est quand même rare parce qu'il sent
bien que c'est la première fois
peut-être qu'il met en jeu sa popularité
au sein de son pays avant il ne
s'adressait il ne s'adressait finalement
à chaque fois cause occidentaux assez
peu à son peuple là il a besoin de son
peuple est-ce que son peuple va le
suivre alors là où je suis pas d'accord
avec vous non
il s'adressait toujours à son peuple
quand il parle d'opération spéciale
c'est c'est surtout à son peuple qui
s'adresse pour dire nous vous inquiétez
pas tout est sous contrôle je comprends
et c'est pour rassurer
évidemment quand il peut admettre qu'il
y a quelques soucis économiques c'est
bien sûr de la faute des
Occidentaux et de leur sanction
mais là effectivement cette mobilisation
c'est pas qui s'adressait au peuple mais
c'est que ça ça crée une vraie panique
c'est dans une partie de la population
russe qui tout d'un coup se dit mais il
va trop loin notre notre Président il
doit rassurer 14h13 nous sommes en
direct depuis le on est au
kremlinez-vous que je ne sais plus c'est
la grande salle Saint-Georges ou pas je
voudrais pas dire de bêtises
enfin c'est un déo les plus prestigieux
je me souviens y être allé pour une
remise de médaille de Jacques Chirac
d'accord quand Jacques Chirac n'était
plus président de la République
et qui avait reçu une des distinctions
les plus prestigieuses donc il y avait
de nombreuses personnalités donc c'est
vraiment oui un grand haul des palais du
Kremlin qui est utilisé pour les les
circonstances les plus solennelles
Fabrice pendant du Figaro à Moscou tout
à l'heure quand vous êtes arrivés on a
commencé à voir ces images vous étiez un
peu un peu surpris par ce que vous voyez
vous attendiez pas forcément à ça c'est
la fête on essaie de montrer que c'est
important que oui le territoire russe
agrandit j'ai lu dans les dépêches que à
Moscou on est on va faire la fête
Presque Oui il paraît que il y a des des
festivités qui sont prévues je ne sais
pas si il y aura beaucoup de gens qui
spontanément se réjouiront parce que le
climat est quand même lourd encore une
fois à cause notamment de cette
mobilisation qui touche tout le monde
mais Vladimir Poutine certainement veut
afficher ça comme une victoire volonté
de peuples opprimé par les nazis
Ukrainiens pour reprendre sa
terminologie qui qui se libère et qui se
qui demande la protection de de l'Etat
russe alors passage vous avez cité tout
à l'heure les quatre régions
ukrainiennes on parle de la région la
région de zapporoïdia
paradoxal on dit la région de zaporigia
or le chef-lieu de cette région la ville
même de zapporisia n'est pas occupé
c'est ça par la Russie elle est encore
en territoire ukrainien souverain on
sait que c'est un endroit une ville vers
laquelle converge énormément de réfugiés
les personnes les Ukrainiens qui
arrivent qui arrive à fuir les personnes
ou de l'Est arrivent affluent beaucoup
de nos reporteurs Margaux ben entre
autres ou
d'autres collègues du Figaro sont allés
recueillir des témoignages sous un
bouleversants asaporigia alors c'est un
nom aussi qui commence un petit peu à
parler aux autres pour cette centrale
auditeurs parce que
c'est pas très loin des aporidia ça fait
quand même quelques dizaines de
kilomètres qu'il y a cette fameuse
centrale nucléaire qui porte le même nom
mais qui en fait alors la centrale elle
est elle est occupée c'est parce qu'elle
est de l'autre côté du fleuve et la
centrale elle est occupée par par les
troupes russes depuis le depuis le mois
de mars donc quasiment le début de
l'année c'est une prise stratégique
évidemment en terme d'énergie puisque
c'est la plus grosse centrale nucléaire
d'Europe 6 réacteurs de mémoire Fabrice
je vous propose qu'on écoute un petit
peu alors j'ai l'impression et que et
que le réalisateur s'est arrêté parce
que tout à l'heure on nous montrait les
visages de toutes ces personnalités qui
sont là beaucoup d'hommes pas de femmes
évidemment on n'est pas forcément
forcément très surtout à l'image à
l'image de la composition de oui du
pouvoir russe on écoute ce qu'il se
passe un petit peu là puis on revient
dans un
l'arrivée de Vladimir Poutine on écoute
le président russe cette allocution très
attendue que va-t-il annoncer ce qui est
prévu c'est et bien l'annonce de ses
annexions de ces quatre régions
ukrainiennes on écoute et on fait un
point régulièrement avec Fabrice
[Musique]
le début de cette prise de parole de
Vladimir Poutine Fabrice alors le
président tout de suite c'est adressé
aux populations des quatre régions
occupées par la Russie les quatre
régions ukrainiennes les incitait Deniel
slogan nous aporez déjà Carson voilà
quatre régions donc où ont été
organisées des référendum selon la
terminologie russe référendum reconnu
par aucun pays étranger qui était
vraiment des parodies il y a certains je
rappelle certains
officiels russes qui se rendaient chez
les personnes à domicile des électeurs
en tout cas Vladimir Poutine très vite a
annoncé que la Russie comptait 4
nouvelles régions il a dit que c'était
plusieurs millions de personnes en
revérifier plusieurs millions de
citoyens russes supplémentaires donc
sous les applaudissements
beaucoup d'officiels russes réunis au
Kremlin Vladimir Poutine on continue de
l'écouter
[Musique]
russe qui
est installé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de silence pour les héros russes c'est
ça c'est ce qui a demandé Vladimir
Poutine oui donc vraiment on sent toute
une mise en scène assez impressionnante
donc la lumière Poutine je répète a
annoncer solennellement l'annexion de
des quatre régions russes ou avait été
organisées des
Occident appelle les simulacres de
référendum et il a cité les dirigeants
de de ces régions d'ailleurs
on voit ici ramzankadirov le président
de la Tchétchénie en région qui fait
partie de la Fédération de Russie elle
depuis l'époque soviétique et même
au-delà de cadirov qui qui des soldats
sont envoyés en Ukraine depuis plusieurs
mois et puis Poutine qui parle encore
des des néonazis oui il reprend
finalement un peu les cette rhétorie
qu'il avait utilisé dans ce discours
très violent qu'il avait fait la veille
de l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine où il
parle du régime nazi il parle de de
de néo-nazis en 2014 référence à cette
révolution de maïdan qui justement où
une partie de la population ukrainienne
c'était soulevée contre le président à
l'époque yanukovitch le président
ukrainien prorus qui a duré en Russie
d'ailleurs et ça a été un tournant
majeur et c'est juste juste après cette
révolution
soulèvement populaire pro-occidental que
la Crimée a été annexée et que une
partie de donbasses a été aussi
occupé par par la Russie à l'époque il
faut le rappelez pas officiellement
c'était des hommes qui ne portaient pas
d'uniforme russe qui qui soutenait les
séparatistes on écoute et on continue
d'écouter Vladimir Poutine
à l'Union soviétique qui agite le
sentiment patriotique il va revenir il
revient quand même à une de ces grandes
obsessions qui qui ont marqué son son
régime depuis le début donc depuis 20
ans vous on se souvient de cette phrase
très importante qu'il a dit quelques
années
plus tard je crois à la conférence de
Munich où il avait dit que la plus
grande catastrophe géopolitique
historique était le démantèlement de
l'Union soviétique et il vient d'y
revenir en disant que finalement tous
les mots que connaissent
l'espace proche de la Russie
proviennent de ce de cet effondrement de
l'empire soviétique que les peuples ont
été arrachés sans qu'on leur demande à
la mère patrie et donc il est en train
de finalement dans ses rêves dans son
idéologie de reconstruire reconstituer
l'empire soviétique on écoute Vladimir
Poutine à nouveau
ça va
un appel un appel à l'Ukraine oui
Vladimir Poutine vient de lancer un
appel au régime de Kiev appel à des
négociations il dit il faut cesser le
combat il rappelle selon lui c'est
l'Ukraine qui a été l'agresseur et il
dit en 2014
pour lui le point de départ c'est
effectivement effectivement cette
révolution de de maïdan il faut quand
même rappeler qu'en 2014 c'est la Russie
qui a annexé la Crimée la Russie qui a
envoyé
renversement populaire et selon lui sous
la botte et le l'égide d'un une mouvance
néonazi oui et puis de toute façon pour
Vladimir Poutine l'Occident a manipulé
la haie manipule l'Ukraine de depuis le
début mais
le temps la main peut-être pas mais en
tout cas il parle de négociation c'est
pas forcément ce qu'il a l'habitude de
faire quand même est-ce que il peut se
contenter en fait il a ses quatre
régions qu'il vient d'annoncer comme
annexé je suis trop contente alors ça
c'est difficile à dire
il se sent quand même je pense en
position actuellement plutôt de
faiblesse puisque encore une fois il y a
quelques semaines l'armée ukrainienne a
effectué une percée assez spectaculaire
dans la région de querquy
elle a pu aussi sur le front sud
venir Poutine pour l'instant soit
cherche à gagner du temps pour renforcer
effectivement ses positions alors c'est
aussi un maître de ce qu'on appelle les
conflits gelés pour y aller c'est
pourrir des situations c'est quand même
ce qu'il a fait en Géorgie ce qu'il a
laissé faire même si c'est le concerne
pas directement mais en Azerbaïdjan avec
le nagorie carabach avec cette petite
région coincée entre la Moldavie et
l'Ukraine qui est la Transnistrie où il
y a des troupes-rusts toujours et
laisser des situations pourrir comme ça
ça permet d'affaiblir les pays qui sont
concernés on écoute à nouveau Vladimir
Poutine où j'ai mis
[Musique]
la cible est très claire là fabrice
est dans une diatribe anti-occidentale
en ressassant cette idée qui parfois
partagée même par certains certains
penseurs en Europe
occidentale en France
il vient de de rejeter la faute à l'OTAN
à l'Occident qui a
soi-disant selon lui affaiblit la Russie
après la chute de l'Union soviétique
qui voulait imposer son modèle alors
c'est c'est une une rhétorique qui est
reprise encore une fois parfois par
certains penseurs y compris en
Occident justement pas seulement des
proches du rassemblement national et qui
est largement qui fait fit quand même de
beaucoup de faits historiques au
tournant des années 90
l'Occident les États-Unis le FMI par
exemple
ont mis des milliards de dollars pour
soutenir l'économie russe ont tendu la
main à la Russie l'ont fait rentrer dans
le G7 devenu le G8
et aujourd'hui Vladimir Poutine enfin
quand je dis aujourd'hui ça fait des
années qu'il réécrit l'histoire en
disant que l'Occident a voulu absolument
affaiblir la Russie la piétiner
la vérité est nettement plus complexe
que ce qu'il veut bien dire mais
évidemment ça parle il s'adresse à son
peuple avant tout et comment comment
rassembler son peuple quand il y a des
doutes quand il y a des de la peur si ce
n'est contre un ennemi extérieur ça
c'est quand même difficile Vladimir
Poutine prend la parole devant devant
les Russes il s'exprime il vient
d'annoncer l'annexion de quatre régions
on continue de l'écoute
[Musique]
contre l'Occident oui on aurait pu
s'attendre à une déclaration
relativement courte alors qu'on a vu
qu'il y avait ce décorum on se doute qui
ne va pas convoquer
tout ce que compte la Russie officielle
pour 5 minutes de discours donc il est
parti pour faire un discours
relativement long avec remise en
perspective historique en brandissant la
menace existentielle c'est ce qu'il
était en train de dire que le modèle la
culture les valeurs même de la Russie
sont menacées par l'Occident par les
néonazis
Ukrainiens évidemment
il va passer entièrement sous silence
les crimes de guerre absolument avérées
désormais commis par les troupes russes
en Ukraine boutcha isomes qui ont été
quand même très très largement documenté
juste avant qu'il ne parle alors c'était
des sources ukrainiennes qui faisaient
état de tirs
qui aurait fait des victimes civiles je
crois justement dans la région de
zaporiggia
évidemment on a un discours qui devait
venir Poutine qui nous donne qu'une
version
de l'histoire et des faits qui se
déroulent en ce moment
occultant totalement les brutes encore
une fois les crimes de guerre commis
depuis 7 mois maintenant par l'armée
russe en Ukraine mais ce qu'on sent
Fabrice c'est qu'il ne parle même pas de
cette derniers mois il parle des 30
dernières années la lumière Poutine il
accuse l'Ouest voilà la teneur pour
l'instant de son discours on continue de
l'écouter
[Musique]
oui il dit que l'Occident s'offusque de
ne reconnaît pas les les référendums qui
ont eu lieu et il a beau jeu souvent de
que l'Occident oui est intervenu en Irak
en Serbie etc pour montrer que
l'Occident fait du deux poids de mesure
mais là en l'espèce
c'est bien la Russie de façon absolument
flagrante qui viole le droit
international quand elle annexe la
Crimée quand elle annexe il y a
maintenant quelques jours 2008 aussi de
région de alors ils n'ont pas été
formellement annexés mais il y a quand
même deux régions de Géorgie qui reste
sous contrôle russe ça se fait violation
absolument flagrante du droit
international et maintenant c'est quatre
régions ukrainiennes annexées à la suite
de simulacre de référendum dans des
régions dont une bonne partie de la
population a fui en Ukraine dont on sait
que les scrutins ont été menés parfois
sans urnes les
officiels russes sont allés chez
personne les ont fiché des gens qui ne
voulaient pas voter ont été arrêtés donc
enfin on sait que c'est une vraiment une
pantalonnade mais Vladimir Poutine
s'adresse avant tout à sa population
tout en adressant évidemment des
messages aux Occidentaux mais quand ils
parlent de défense existentielle de la
Russie il s'adresse avant tout à son
peuple on continue de l'écouter Vladimir
Poutine
this Google
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des accusations cette diatribe
antioxydante ça fait maintenant presque
20 minutes il n'a parlé quasiment que de
ça
complètement oui ce qui est encore une
fois n'est pas de nouveau ça fait
vraiment partie de sa rhétorique
laquelle c'est affirmé ces derniers
temps il accuse l'Occident d'absolument
tous les tous les mots d'être
une dictature colonialiste
encore une fois alors il s'adresse à la
fois à son à son public mais on pourrait
concitoyens on peut penser aussi d'une
certaine manière il peut essayer de
s'adresser à des pays non alignés à ces
pays en Afrique par exemple ou la Russie
est en train d'entretenir assez
savamment sentiment anti français par
exemple au Mali en Centrafrique
ou la Russie donc avance ses pions et
c'est cette rhétorique effectivement qui
là depuis 20 minutes c'est assez
impressionnant et jusqu'ici il n'a pas
il n'a pas brandi vraiment de menaces il
n'a pas parlé de North stream
il faudra voir d'ici là la fin de la
journée on va voir nos confrères du
service étranger notamment vont analyser
ce discours par dans le détail et les
réactions évidemment qu'il va susciter
il a dit vous le voyez le Fabrice tout
le monde sur cette dépêche qui nous
parvient il a à parler des larmes
nucléaires les seuls à l'avoir utilisé
c'est les Américains au Japon voilà ce
que nous dit Vladimir Poutine merci de
m'avoir accompagné Fabrice je sais que
je suis obligé de vous libérer parce que
vous avez des papiers à écrire pour le
pour le finir économie vous continuez à
suivre Vladimir Poutine on l'écoute vous
avez aussi sur le Figaro.fr et bien tout
ce qu'il dit exactement en détail avec
la traduction nous on continue de
l'écouter en version originale merci
beaucoup continuez à nous suivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà ce qu'on pouvait écouter de
Vladimir Poutine long discours plus long
que prévu devant à partir d'officiel
russe qu'en retenir vous l'avez pu le
suivre en version originale si vous ne
parlez pas reçu c'est bien on peut vous
dire ça y est que Vladimir Poutine a
officiellement annoncé l'annexion de
quatre régions
ukrainiennes de nietz clougansk zapporja
et Carson une une annexion qui a été
immédiatement rejetée par l'Union
européenne pas trop de suspense pas trop
de doute sur le fait que l'ONU l'Europe
l'OTAN n'accéderont pas et ne valideront
pas l'annexion de ces de ces régions que
Vladimir Poutine est en train de de
parapher vous le voyez sur ces sur ces
images il a accusé lors d'une très très
longue diatribe Occident de vouloir
faire de la Russie une colonie
l'Occident opposé à la Russie sans pour
autant vouloir la restauration l'URSS
même s'il y a fait référence à de
nombreuses reprises et puis Vladimir
Poutine a aussi accusé les Occidentaux
d'être à l'origine des fuites de North
stream ces deux gazoduc Nord Stream Nord
Stream 2 c'est de gazoduc qui relie
l'Ukraine la Russie à certains pays
d'Europe notamment l'Allemagne voilà ce
que nous pouvions dire de cette
intervention de Vladimir Poutine qui n'a
pas fait état de menace directe de
l'arme nucléaire c'est ce qui était à
craindre mais il a dit que dorénavant
évidemment c'est quatre régions de nietz
Logan qui vaporidia et Carson c'est
quatre régions ukrainiennes étaient
désormais russe que les personnes qui
habitaient devenaient des citoyens
russes et donc qu'il serait défendu en
conséquence voilà je vous laisse avec
ces images de ces traités qui sont en
train d'être paraphés par les officiels
russes et plats Vladimir Poutine merci
de nous avoir suivi excellente journée
sur le figaroller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]